connaissez-vous les banques d'image en
gros ce sont des sites sur lesquels je
peux trouver plein d'image et tu vas
pouvoir en méga hd tu vas pour acheter
ces images pour illustrer été arctique
ou pour faire ta miniature tu as tu as
besoin d'un mec je crois qu'il mange ses
crottes de nez tu tapes mais qui mange
ses crottes de nez tu vas trouver ses
marques plus aucun résultat
correspondant à secteur n'a été trouvé
bon je vais peut-être inventeur hockey
bref là où je veux en venir c'est que
ces sites normands comporte des photos
qui sont pas trop at the fuck ok je te
re stock cars 2 3 et rêve deposit photo
c'est les trois plus gros je crois moi
même j'ai utilise donc je me dis ah
carrière de celle où dessus là où je
veux en venir
j'ai trouvé hier un site japonais voilà
vous savez que ça excellent bizarre qui
s'appelle ne retient le web point j p ce
site répond à la demande de 1 % des
clients maniaque des infirmières donc
c'est une banque d'image en ligne comme
les autres mais c'est que des photos
d'infirmières et c'est extrêmement
bizarre déjà on va les découvrir
ensemble j'en ai vu deux j'ai vu celle
avec le gorille âge là il n'a aucun sens
avec cet homme qui en profonde
dépression depuis des années j'en ai vu
une autre mais je veux pas me spoil pour
découvrir avec vous et surtout on va
essayer de trouver des titres à ces
images et pour sa twitter va nous aider
ce parti voilà un étranger à part cet
effet loupe ignoble qui n'existe plus
depuis 2002 sur internet gmail etc ceci
tu sais que tu peux télécharger l'image
au format téléphone pour que quand tu
prends le numéro d'une fille elle voit
des fonds d'écran elles partent en
courant en appelant la police en mec là
on commence à des choses bizarres
non c'est quoi je crois que c'est des
réservoirs dans lesquels tu es censé
uriner balagan tu peux pas bouger à
l'hôpital max était content d'avoir
cette cet objet celle lâchée objet de
vous la partagez elle est d'une
puissance colossale alors trouver un
site à cette image comment faire des
squats
j'ai bien aimé le seigneur des anneaux
japon je n'ai pas du tout compris la
blague
tu ne passeras pas vous ne passerez pas
ok ça blague a fait l'unanimité il
faudra me passer sur le corps pour que
je puisse là dedans un peu long mais
sympathique alors vous une autre image
le loup mais c'est dépourvu de tout sens
pour parler correctement comme cette
coupe de cheveux d'elle il ya eu un
effort on est partis d'hôpital on a
trouvé un katana en chemin c'est fou tu
es mort or une photo normale car ça fait
plaisir aux une photo mois normal c'est
quoi ça vous donner les photomontages de
certains l'avaient à la fois c'est fou
adacore veut qu'on a volé une cabine
téléphonique pour faire cette photo très
bien mes mecs c'est là je veux qu'on
veut a commenté elle est trop belle pour
être ignorée j'essaye d'avaler une
abeille grâce à une paille ça tourne
assez puissant aveugle elle confond son
mojito avec une fleur dutchess
d'abdullah c'est quoi
à mon avis c'est un instant s'il de
cuisine elle vient de remettre les
cheveux qui est bizarre c'est qu'elle
elle revient pas elle regarde ailleurs à
vous elle a commenté salah je m'ennuie
donc je poste des photos de chinois sur
twitter et je travaille au quai un peu
de respect pour les gens qui travaillent
en plus c'est pas les chinois c'est des
japonais hockey plus tard tu apprendras
gones n'a tout ça sans quoi pas bras en
manque d'idées de vidéos de la part de
sécuriser la vidéo soit nous paraître
fade maintenant après avoir lu cette
phrase cinq fruits et légumes par jour
mais laïque et pas les gars ce n'est
même pas drôle
[ __ ] c'était hyper drôle on a rigolé
replay gurnari au québec c'était la
première page je sais ce que c'était le
truc avance était un appareil pour faire
de la glace pilée voilà elle le fait sur
la tête du passé en cra quel bel hôpital
c'est insensé
j'ai compris il faut tourner la tête je
vais vous montrer en fait c'est une
illusion d'optique mais ils oubliaient
de tourner la photo avant de la poster
sur le site
en réalité si vous tournez l'image à 45°
vous avez une illusion d'optique veut
pas max ça se voit totalement que le sol
c'est sa [ __ ] tu m as tu as déjà vu un
mur ou cette couleur bas n'ont même pas
mais parce qu'il ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de sol du coup mais j'ai pas compris
si longtemps et de faire qu'est ce que
c'est que ce mime ça veut dire quoi mais
c'est complètement con il n'y a pas de
sol sous le canal du coup ça ne marche
pas au [ __ ] je me prends la tête la
mecque
j'aimerais lire le japonais juste pour
lire ce qu'assure ce papier l'art pour
pouvoir comprendre les animés en vo m'en
bats les couilles
on pourra racheter les manga au japon et
quand même pouvoir les lire bats les
couilles j'aimerais parler japonais
juste pour pouvoir lire ce qui doit
marquer ce petit papier six régions il
parle japonais dites nous où là
hockey ici ils ont tenté la blague d'une
cep shon ils marchent pas trop mais où
on en est si quelqu'un souhaite planète
arrive à calais cette image pour
illustrer l'une de ces miniatures ou
article eh ben ils gagnent suse studio
allez je me casse
salut en vrai on dirait pas mais c'est
dur d'avoir des bonnes idées pour faire
du what the fuck comme ça là encore ça
va ya du sang celle du fait d'une petite
brochette elle prend soin de lui il est
à l'hôpital depuis trois mois il a un
très très gros rhume bon voilà par
exemple cette photo là un peu moins de
sens balader une pomme avec un bras de
godzilla c'est étrange elle en obtient 3
celle là elle est folle à la caisse que
vous m'avez trouvé comme titre pour
cette image là face à une compote pas
mal japon les fruits à mobilité réduite
ou ne les oublie pas ses bons amis qui
savent ce que tu dis [ __ ]
apple va mal c'est beau ça c'est
décidément très difficile de se
masturber devant ces images
j'avoue c'est plus simple de se
masturber devant celle là par exemple
qu'est-ce qui est jaune et qui pousse
une pomme
non non non ok images suivantes 1 mais
qu'est ce qui se passe là jsk par
message bulgarie faisait à travers cette
image donnant de l'importance aux fruits
mais c'est sûr et certain
ils ont juste loués à des cordes hôpital
et j'ai essayé de faire le plus de trucs
qu'on avec ce qu'il y avait autour de
mes [ __ ] avec ça marche pas à chaque
fois que a le mauvais soit the bulls a
d'abord envie de voir les rôles qui
s'avère un peu la [ __ ] les mecs je
pense vraiment qu avec toutes ces images
on pourrait faire une bd on pourrait
faire une vraie histoire dont il ya
toutes les situations possibles gars
mais tu peux totalement faire une
histoire aux balles à un poste il a
seulement elle mérite de la mettre en
fond d'écran je suis désolé voilà elle
est tellement belle
non mais arrêtez avec ça la viande crue
sur le bras nus on arrête tout de suite
tu en veux bien y'a pas de soucis et
sept personnes en font au casque jaune
ne se pose aucune question par rapport à
ce qui se passe à dix mètres d'elle donc
c'est dans la catégorie échec et
abordons de travail
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez changer de
vie arrêter du jour au lendemain a
accroché une seringue au bout d'un fil
de fer reliant votre tête le message est
clair
infirmière un visage douteuses depuis
que j'ai vu mon cheveu de vous et qu'est
ce que tu vas faire cette image les
infirmières ont trouvé un châtaignier
mec je te jure regarder ces trois images
des truites j'atteigne puis elle
s'apprête à la ramasse et qu elle
abandonne et 120 tu peux faire une bande
dessinée le fait que je te jure on a un
concept infirmières montrant son courage
et deux coupes des ciseaux dans la
bouche ça c'est le visage que tu fais
quand tu montres ton courage vous manque
un vrai que j'ai eu très peu de courage
dans ma vie ça va le par sur twitter ça
l'art de la livre prend que je me coupe
la langue
en fait je trouve que à force des
parodies de titres publics c'est plus du
tout de rôle d'un ça devient un peu
comme le moma les antes a plutôt envie
de le dire est ce que du coup on devient
des cons
a trouvé ça nul parce que tout le monde
se met à le faire mais qui du coup est
le vrai compte celui qui fait ce que
tout le monde fait ou celui qui critique
un truc parce que tout le monde le fait
amedi terre de débat ne doit pas avoir
lieu dans cette vidéo vidéo dans
laquelle nous voyons des images comme
celles ci ça ne va pas je donne ma
langue au chat
pas mal aux [ __ ] en finit par la plus
belle l'infirmière qui souffre dans un
grand coquillage c'est un grand oui
magnifique et balader mais c'est de la
faute cette vidéo sur la banque d'image
en ligne la plus bizarre de la planète
ne s'est pas laissée vous a plu mec ça
doit être génial quand ton métier sait
où est un endroit mais deux personnes
dedans et leur dire de faire que de la
merde risque est bien dans tout ça c'est
que maintenant je saurai où aller pour
trouver des images pour mais miniature
allez à bientôt là je crois qu'on est
parfaitement dans le thème
[Musique]
ça